hello everyone and welcome to a video
where we are going to discuss
uh in length uh why rashida about medina
never got his title of grand master
why did it happen why was it was he not
able to
to to you know win games was he just not
awarded opportunities to face stronger
players or
what was the cause of this because you
know i don't know it was maybe some
three or four years ago
uh the channel had less than maybe even
50
000 subscribers and i said uh during
numerous
streams that if my channel ever reaches
uh one million subscribers that i would
uh
send a formal petition to feed a uh
requesting to grant um
uh rashid medina the title of grand
master now
uh i never thought that the channel
would actually reach 1 million
subscribers but now of course i have to
revisit
that remark and um uh
it's not possible to award uh someone a
grandmaster title
of course after he has died but it is
possible to award uh someone
the title of honorary grand master is it
the same thing
uh well in terms of uh any privileges or
rights that a grandmaster might have yes
it's the same thing but is it really the
same thing
uh not really because uh uh
up to 2003 fide awarded the grand master
title
30 31 times and i'm you know i i don't
think you can name even one honorary
grand master
uh because i mean even though it it kind
of is the title of grand master
it doesn't um uh i mean
it's not let's face it it's not so here
uh in this video i'm gonna
talk a little bit about um uh about
rashid
medina and uh how he did not get a
chance to play
all all that many tournaments uh why
that was so
and we're gonna show a very nice game
here that he played against the
grandmaster vladimir on torsion
uh which is basically the game that he
feels
is um uh well the
the this game is the reason that he did
not get his grand master title but not
only the game
there is one specific move that nish
medina himself
claims that robbed him of his
grandmaster title or rather the
opportunity to be granted the
grandmaster title
then we're going to do a little bit of a
summary and then you guys will decide
what's best as i still can to make up my
mind
so here for those of you who are not
interested in this article you're
welcome to skip to the
game but i encourage you to to stay uh
with the article as it features uh
a lot of very interesting uh uh stuff
and you know you will increase your vast
knowledge at least tenfold
so that being said let's check it out so
that the article
i will now show you is from the chess
federation of the republic of tatarstan
it's uh in tatar so uh the the
my interface is translated into english
but it's not all that correct so here i
found
on chess.com there is a gentleman named
spektrowski who
translated this to proper english and
now uh this is what we will use
so let's check it out as it states here
this is an excerpt
from the book the chess history of
tataria by marat kazanov published at
the tatarsan republic chess federation
site
and here's the link that you can click
on i will also put a link to this in the
description below if you prefer just
reading it yourself and then checking
out the game because i'm i will i'm not
going to read all of it but i will
read the the most important parts so it
says as niche medino's name became more
well known uh people often ask
if he's a grandmaster string player and
if he was why didn't he become one
so i often heard chess fans asking
rashid about which himself about that he
would literally explode there were no
tournaments he would scream and of
course uh he had a different version for
the press
uh it's not that there were no
tournaments is just that
there were no tournaments for him and
we're gonna we're gonna get
get to that so let's check that medina
could really become a grand master in
1954 to 1958 when he was
on his performance peak how many grand
master tournaments were held in the ussr
back then
and that's exactly one it was the alejan
memorial of 1956
where five grand masters represented the
soviet union between x mislove
karis bronstein and the mark taimanov
masters were not invited to such
tournaments so nez medina have never had
a chance of of winning any norms
and uh now let's look at which soviet
players did become grand masters in that
period uh where
rashid gabbat which was considered to be
the strongest in 1954
nobody got a grandmaster title from the
soviet union in 1955
only one player for a future world
champion boris posky
and he won it um not not by pure chance
of course he played very well but it was
uh
it was it was definitely a stroke of
luck he won the youth world championship
and
qualified for the interzonal tournament
where he got his grand masters norm
but boris was very lucky the world
championship in anther
ended on the 8th of august and the
interzonal which luckily was held in
gutenberg
began in one week on the 15th of august
and spassky got there in time
which considering the soviet bureaucracy
of the time was quite a feat in itself
uh in 1956 again only one player was
awarded
the the grand master title that it's
viktor korchnoy
and in 1957 again only one player
mikhail tal
uh who won the soviet championship so in
1958 and 1959
no soviet players became grand master so
in those six years from 1954 to 1959
only three soviet players became grand
masters spas guitar
and victor korchnoy and those are not
just players those are absolute monsters
those are
those are legends so uh i mean
that puts uh puts it puts uh his chance
a little bit uh into perspective
and how is niche medina supposed to
become a grandmaster if he never played
a tournament with the grand master norms
now uh the the author also says that
younger players might ask okay
but if there were no tournaments in the
ussr why didn't he just go abroad and
play and win some norms
uh the problem is uh that the the soviet
people
lived behind the iron curtain as he
states uh this term was popularized by
winston churchill who said in march 1946
in fulton
the iron curtain came down across the
whole continent so soviet citizens were
forbidden to go abroad without express
permission from the authorities
and even on 8th 8th of june 1935 a law
was passed
that punished escaping through the state
border with execution
with the criminals relatives getting
punished too so not only were you
getting punished but also
your family could get in trouble as well
in 1962 of course nobody was executed
anymore but
the leningrad city court sentenced the
defector rudolf nurev
at the seven years of imprisonment and
confiscation of property for treason
so although you don't get executed i
mean you you kind of lose everything
any contacts with foreigners had to be
approved by the authorities or else you
could have ended up
in jail very few players could play
abroad at this time
so uh as you can see medinav could not
play within the ussr but
you you couldn't really go anywhere you
wanted in those days
so uh korchner also remembers uh medina
he said
i played my first tournament after my
marriage in sochi this was the russian
championship and it was won by ninja
medina one of the strongest soviet
masters
for some reason he was very rarely
allowed to go abroad and obviously he
never became a grandmaster because of
that
medina was awarded the international
master title after finishing second in
bucharest in 1954
that was probably the strongest foreign
tournament uh he played in
and uh was niche medina the grand master
strength player
uh here are some of his results so here
you can see the results of the 18th
russian
championship in sochi 18 1958 where nish
medina won first place
there is also the soviet championship
semi-final in the rostov
in 1958 also nege medina wins first
place
and here we have the ussr team
championship in villainous uh in 1958
where he played board one
uh he scored four and a half out of
eight so
you might think four and a half out of
eight isn't all that impressive but uh
the the lineup in this tournament is
just insane so there's column of
courtney geller uh charis bronstein
bolas lavsky
and says uh with the exception of
srishnov and zilber who finished last
everyone else here was a super grand
master and
scoring four and a half out of eight
here so that's over fifty percent
uh in such a field is uh definitely
worthy worthy of a grandmaster norm and
rashid gabatto which was an equal
footing with all these
uh all this chess elite his results
obviously showed that uh
at his career peak in 1956 to 1958
medina reached the grand master level
this is also proven mathematically
there's this website called chess
metrics where you can check
how strong would for example capablanca
be if he
uh had uh you know if he lived today and
had
such results against uh against his
contemporaries
nowadays and it says here that um
uh here he would be rated 2706 so that's
an
incredible rating and uh he would be
ranked 21st in the world
yeah and uh not just in the soviet union
uh alex alexis suet and said that uh
i'm sure that now niche medina would
surely get his grand master norm
but he was born too early and here we
also say uh i can see that
uh belloccotti of uh in his book about
niche medina also asked the question
why such a brilliant player failed to
reach the olympus of chess art failed to
become a grand master
i asked madinov himself about that very
delicately
and the rashid gabata which smoothed out
his champions band
thought for thought for a long time then
said many chess fans
asked me this question they can't
understand why i didn't get
the grand master title frankly there's
nothing surprising about that
prominent players such as bothwinix
mistletoe spasky fisher
performed brilliantly already at the age
of 15 both in their countries and abroad
and i was only beginning to study chess
at that age all modern grandmasters had
a solid theoretical base around age 20
becoming masters there was a 20-year gap
between them and
me and this obviously was the main
obstacle that didn't allow me to become
a grandmaster
it's only logical the master's answer
was very simple and clear
so here we have a bit of a rasheed's
insight into why the grand master title
eluded him
although this was all uh maybe also a
prepared response because you couldn't
you know just say anything you you you
wanted back then
uh and um yeah
i mean you you could read the entire
article but uh i'm
i'm just gonna go through some more
important parts uh still niche medina
did get a chance to become a grandmaster
and
this is where our game that we are now
covering uh
com comes into play uh during sorry
about that
uh during the khrushchev star uh soviet
players started getting more
opportunities to play in
international tournaments and so when
nish medina was almost
52 years old he was finally invited to a
tournament in sochi with a grand master
norm
in those times you only had to get a
single norm to become a grand master the
age
to the the age already took its toll and
rashid
which was past his peak but he still
fought on and he uh played a very
impressive tournament and what won
a lot of great games uh even one against
boris paske it says
uh after four rounds ninja medina had
two points and played white against
boris posky already a world championship
candidate at that
point spasky sacrificed an exchange and
got some compensation but after the
adjournment
nish medinov gave the exchange back and
created an unstoppable mating attack
some games were good some really bad uh
and in one of the last rounds
nishmedinov played against uh antoshin
this was the decisive game i'm putting
it here without much commentary but we
are of course
going to cover it uh and uh all right
we're gonna skip uh rest of the article
so i'm just gonna finish with this and
then we're going to check out the game
but like i said it will be in the
description below you're welcome to go
uh through all of it yourself uh
so uh here uh let's just continue this i
wanted to just mention one more part
uh yeah rasheed gabatovich was a very
impulsive man and the losses upset him
quite heavily probably due to that in
the next round is medina agreed to a
draw in a better position after just 23
moves and he couldn't make grandmaster
norm by one
one and a half point so this is uh
referring to this game that we are
showing but we're gonna get back to that
uh and also he scored eight and a half
out of the needed ten
the fact that six years passed his peak
aged 52 and medina still managed to
score
85 percent of a grand master's norm only
proves that
during his most stellar performances uh
rasheed gabatovich was a grandmaster
strength player but simply never had a
chance to achieve that elusive norm
and after he turned 46 it was already
hard for him
to withstand the intensity of the
tournaments your memory uh
your your memory can't register the
novelties all that well
your calculation skills get numbed it's
pure physiology
medina was sure that if he won the game
against antoshin
he would have gotten his norm uh he he
would emotionally share his sorrow with
many people
managing to convince most of them
obviously if he won that game he
wouldn't have made
the quick draw the next day so rasheed
batwich was pretty sure that a single
chessboard square
decided everything for him and that's
what we're going to cover in this game
uh but you know it's very tricky he was
very upset
he thought that if he moved his bishop
just one square further
he would he would have become a
grandmaster a ridiculous accident
though to say the truth uh the there's
nothing accidental
in my humble opinion niece medinav
didn't like bishop to a8
because after that he would have had to
convert his material advantage in a long
and boring end game but he wanted to
checkmate his opponent
but okay now we're just gonna switch to
the game because uh
i i'm imagining you would prefer to see
the game first
uh then to just hear about it so that
means said uh let's check out the game
so uh here uh here we have it uh rasheed
medina versus vladimir
tonjin uh uh medina with the white
pieces and he opens
with e4 so let's see this uh game that
uh you know
uh uh uh
stole the the grand master title uh from
niz medinav so e4
uh we have e6 uh going for the french
defense we have d3 and
d5 now striking in the center uh here uh
we have knight to d2
defending the e4 pawn and now comes
knight to f6 both players just
developing we have g3 by rashid
preparing to fiance to the light square
bishop
and b6 now black does the same we have
bishop to g2
and now bishop to b7 and now as this
pawn
can be advanced further on e5 now
forcing this knight to move we have
knight f to d7 and now uh continuing
development with knight
g to f3 and black now of course grabs
more space in the center with c5 and
this is all
still uh played today uh we have castles
by rasheed
and now knights the c6 uh with a double
attack on the e pawn so rook to e1
defending the pawn
and now queen to c7 adding a third
attacker to the pawn here
and queen to e2 rashid adds a third
defender here we have
h6 uh and now h4 uh we have g5
uh now saying that okay i'm going to
castle queen side i'm going to open up
your king side and i'm going to attack
you on the king's side
so rashid captures on g5 we have h
captures and
knight knight capture so anto um uh
antoshin uh sacrifices a pawn
and he wants the he wants to attack
rashid uh and here the question is
whether you now recapture on e5 or not
the problem is if queen captures
uh then let's say everything gets traded
off uh queen captures knight captures
and now
uh a lot of moves can be played for
example f4 can be played
uh you could play uh something else you
could play uh
just uh develop the knight here but
there's also the tricky knight to c4 and
probably why
antoshen decided to go against this line
because now
there's a there's a lot to a lot to
evaluate here for example if you capture
the knight
bishop captures here attacks the rook
and if rook moves the bishop to a6 now
and
it's not not an easy position to to
evaluate and
you kind of want to keep things simple
you don't want to over over complicate
against medina
so instead after this knight captures on
g5 we have knight to d for first
attacking the queen now the queen has to
move as the c2 pawn will fall so queen
d1 is the only move and only now
knight captures an e5 so antoshen keeps
the queens on the board
we have c3 pushing the knight away and
now knight to f5
uh and here well you could continue this
game in a lot of ways uh you can see
that black really is mounting a nice
attack this bishop might come to d6 then
both of the bishops will be
eyeing that king's side the the h file
for the rook is open and
rasheed uh or doesn't want to be on the
defensive
uh he jumps into the attack and he does
so by rook captures on e5 so now
he sacrifices the exchange there's only
one move for black black has to capture
uh the rook so queen captures on e5 and
now queen to a4 with
check so now black definitely loses
castling privileges
queen king to e7 and now knight d to f3
pushing the queen back
and preparing to develop the dark square
bishop with bishop to f4
uh we have queen to c7 and now not
going for that right away first he
switches the queen over to g4 so just
queen to g4 uh if you if you go for
bishop to f4 right away
yeah you could play it but then queen to
c6 offers a queen trade and
there is really no good aggressive
square for
for white and rashid prefers to keep the
queens on the board so instead
after this queen to c7 move we have
queen to g4
and now okay now it's definitely white
who's on the attack
uh so here we have knight g to e7
and this is uh this is a very uh very
good move because if black plays
something slow let's say
black plays something like a6 uh danger
lurks in the position you cannot allow
bishop to f4
uh with an attack on the queen because
after the queen moves you get rook to e1
uh with all of these
uh crazy threats here now queen captures
an f5 a threat because the
uh e pawn is pinned and now if the
knight moves now you can just
capture an f7 and that's it uh you've
completely shattered black's defenses of
course if black captures knight e5
check wins the queen so uh the position
is very very poisonous so after this
queen to g4 move we have knights the g7
not allowing any any of this to come
with tempo and now
uh not immediately with bishop to f4
bishop to f4 now
would run into f5 that's the idea behind
knight to g7 and torsion
uh playing very well here and uh anders
medina couldn't really
claim any advantage here now the queens
have to come come off the board
so instead after knight to g7 we have
knight the h4 by rashid
and now uh you can't really push the f
pawn because
knight the g6 check will be deadly so we
have king to e8 not allowing any
uh such moves to come with check and now
again rashid
uh again not ready to go bishop to f4
first strikes with c4
puts pressure on d5 and also wants to
open up this diagonal and here
the thing is if you go d captures on c4
first bishop to f4
and it's a very very difficult position
for black to play after
uh after the queen moves queen to d7 for
example then the knight comes to e4
you're already threatening
knight f6 check to win the queen and uh
it is a playable position but it is very
complicated so instead after this c4
move we have rook to d8
brings the rook into the game and now c
captures on the e5 we have bishop
captures on the e5 and now
knight to e4 keeping the bishops on the
board and now again
uh preparing to you know cause some
trouble here with knight to f6
check so here uh we have bishop captures
on e4
there was a a slight improvement here
knights the h5
is an incredibly strong move for black
because uh
uh now the knight prevents a knight to
f6 check the knight cannot be captured
there it's on an excellent square
it's also preparing bishop to g7 to
continue development for black then the
bishop can come into the game the rook
can come into the game
so knight h5 although uh very uh you
know
weird looking it's actually pretty great
so here after knight to e4 we have
bishop captures on e4 instead
bishop captures and now knight to h5 so
a bit of a different move order but now
the knight finds its way to h5
and now the thing is uh here rashid goes
queen to f3
uh the problem is if you continue with
bishop to g5 which
seems like a normal developing move the
problem is black is very happy to trade
here
bishop e7 and after captures and
captures for example queen g5
check there's king d7 and the black king
escapes
and if you try to do something like d4
to try and open up the c
file for example for the rook it's not a
problem because black has this tricky
knight captures on g3
and that's the problem f captures on g3
rook d to g8 and now it's black who's on
the attack
and white is white is done for here
you're going to have to give up a piece
to simply close off the the g file but
still just
d captures on c5 and after queen
captures with
check the queens get traded off for
example and the black is just winning so
although you want to develop that dark
square bishop it just never seems to be
the
the the appropriate time to do so and
now the knight on h5
also prevents bishop to f4 so the knight
on h5 uh
is is just a brilliant piece so here
rashid goes queen to f3
he puts pressure on a nut on the queen
obviously
but on c6 bishop the c6 check is coming
so here we have queen to e5
again an incredibly strong move by and
torsion uh
not only will the king now be super safe
here
but also bishop to g5 check moves are
not possible the queen is guarding that
and also you will have additional
support in the future for
for f6 so here we have bishop to d2
uh there's always time to play bishop to
c6 check not really doing anything here
and here rasheed offers a pawn otherwise
bishop the c3 is coming and then white
wins material
and here again a very very complicated
position i will
uh mention what what the the absolute
best move here
uh but uh uh evolution went for queen
capture sun beat
queen to f6 is actually the way to go
but again it's super complicated and
uh of course you can't afford all the
time in the world to calculate
but the thing is you offer a queen trade
and after rashid declines now you play
bishop to g7
and now after bishop the c3 with an
attack on the queen
uh queen has to move and now uh things
uh
can get traded off but now the thing is
knight to g6 so this is what rashid uh
would probably have played if it if it
came to this but the problem
for white is that this is okay for black
and now uh you can just capture here
of course you don't want to capture the
knight then you allow queen captures on
e6 and so on but first you eliminate
the bishop now comes the bishop the c6
with
check as it the nice uh the knight
nicely covers e7 and f8 squares
rook to d7 blocking and now you white
really doesn't have anything better but
to trade everything off knight captures
an h8 bishop captures an h8
and now you can capture on d7 captures
with check captures and now queen a4
check you
start going after the queen side pawns
king to d6 and now queen captures on a7
and now we get this position where you
have a rook against a knight and the
bishop
but uh uh you know all in all black
black should be better for example
bishop to d4 preparing to put some
pressure on f2
king to g2 and pinning it now knight
captures and g3 is a threat so king g2
we're gonna play queen to d2 now again
put pressure on the f2 pawn
queen captures on f7 defending and now
finally knight to f6 and now the queen
can capture on f2 so you have to play
rook to f1
it's kind of passive for white and the
black should be very happy
with this position uh if anything it's
black who's pushing for a win here
so uh velocity could have gone for this
queen to f6 idea but
he i guess he didn't want to allow this
bishop to find this beautiful outpost he
played
queen captures on b2 and now he also
attacks the bishop here
so here we have bishop the c6 check uh
king has to move king to e7
and now bishop to g5 with check and
finally
f6 uh df6 is now nicely defended by the
knight and by the queen
uh interestingly if you go knight to f6
that makes little sense it immediately
loses the game
knight to f5 check just uh destroys
black after he captures you
you bring the rook into the game with
check king to d6 and now just bishop to
f4 with
check uh there are no moves for the
black king you have to play queen to e5
and that's it queen e5 bishop captures
with
check and you're very quickly getting
checkmated so instead after bishop to g5
we have
f6 volation defense uh and rashid goes
knight to g6 with
check if king to f7 you lose on the spot
uh because
uh the knight captures an h8 comes with
check so you have to go the other way
kink to d6 and now comes rook to e1
uh white rook is hanging on a1 so you
have to move it rook to e1
and now comes f captures and g5 and this
is indeed the strongest move
uh for black it's not just some you know
random material grabbing move
it is in fact the the strongest move so
f captures on g5 and
now we get uh to the position that's
been haunting rasheed
his entire life uh this is the position
that he claims that
robbed him of his grandmaster title so
feel free to pause the video here and uh
you know try to find
the the absolute best movie in the
position while while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations
on not playing uh bishop to b7
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's actually bishop to
a8
and this is the move uh rasheed was so
angry with his with himself that he
didn't find
the problem with the move bishop to b7
is yes you are
threatening queen to c6 checkmate but
there's a very easy defense to this uh
the the
there's just king to c7 and this is what
rashid
missed uh and after king to c7 the
problem is that the king can now
escape the b8 the problem with the move
bishop to e
bishop to a8 that rasheed did not play
uh that it's extremely complicated now
black really has to figure out how to go
about this
as you are still threatening checkmate
this still will be checkmate the knight
is covering these two squares the e5 and
d7 squares
and with uh torsion being very low on
time rasheed
thought that he will have excellent
chances here the problem is
anything other than giving up the
exchange loses the game and
just to give you an example for example
if you play rook to c8 you guard against
queen to c6 checkmate
it's not a problem bishop to b7 now
again attacks the rook the the rook has
to move and you still have to guard
against checkmate
so here uh rook the c7 obviously only
move
and now comes the move that's uh
probably the one that rasheed missed
when deciding uh whether to even go for
this or i don't know
and that move is d4 this is the only
winning move in the position
the point is that you have to uh block
queen's defense of the rook here on h8
and now everything is simply working in
white's favor and it's very easy to miss
this
the point is uh if you capture with the
queen queen captures on d4 just rook d1
and you win the queen uh if you don't do
that if you do something else for
example you just continue developing
bishop to g7
you say okay i might give back some
material still
insufficient because now rook captures
an e6
check uh destroys black king captures
and now queen to d5 with
check king to f6 and now queen to d6
with
check king to f7 and now bishop to d5
with
checks so this is pretty crazy stuff
king the e8
and now again bishop the c6 with check
so now the king has to go to f7
now we grab an h8 with check bishop
captures and finally the rook is
captured with
check so queen captures on c7 with check
king to f8
and now we get this position uh where uh
black is still up a piece but it doesn't
matter because white is uh
white is able to to win back at least
one if not both of them so here
queen to d8 check king to g7 doesn't
matter what
what black plays uh queen captures on g5
with the check
king to f8 and now you even go queen to
h6 with the check you want to pick up uh
the the piece while delivering check so
king is seven
now comes queen captures on h8 and this
is the best way to go because it now uh
defends the knight okay you didn't win
the piece with
check but you are threatening to win uh
to win material here and now the problem
is
uh there's no good way to defend the
knight if you go knight f6 just queen to
g7 check then d5
and you will win the remaining material
and if queen to b1 with check
king the g2 uh there's again no
no good move for black the absolute best
for black is knight to f4
check here now if uh pawn captures then
you have this queen to g6 check
winning the bishop on c6 but uh white
can just ignore you
aking to h2 and now the thing is uh
again
what do you play here the pawn is just
marching up the board now you don't have
to worry about
any checks uh also pawn captures knight
is a possibility
and here we would have the absolute best
queen to f5 now threatening uh
quint h3 check and after you give up the
this piece uh now queen captures an f4
and now you might be hoping for
for some sort of a perpetual but it will
not be possible
king g1 you're gonna go queen to g4
check now the bishop blocks bishop
can just block this and after c captures
on d4
yes you do have a pass pawn but not just
queen to e5 with
check king to f7 and now queen to e4
offering a queen trait we have queen to
d1 check and bishop to f1
and now with the with the complete
control of the d3 square
it's only a matter of time uh before you
actually
uh before you actually uh manage this uh
so this is
what would happen if this if this is
played after
bishop to a8 uh yeah i mentioned that uh
you you could also capture the bishop
for example rook captures an a8 and
this is the only way to play this uh
rook captures uh because
what would follow is queen captures an
a8
just grabbing that rook and now knight
captures on g3 and this is
uh the absolute the absolute top defense
for black that
uh offers him uh brilliant counter play
and here we have to figure out how to go
about the position
obviously you cannot capture the knight
the knight is off limits maybe you can
capture the rook
so what happens if you just pick up the
rook the problem is now you play knights
to e to check first
and after the king moves now you capture
the knight here because now rook
captures is impossible
um if you go for rook captures on e2
then just
bishop the g7 and you have a nice uh
nice queen trade offering and also the
queen cannot leave the defense of the h1
square because
queen to h1 would be checkmate so this
would be
this would be perfectly fine for black
on the other hand
after this uh after this knight the g3
move
uh maybe okay since you can't capture
that what actually happens if you
capture the knight well
then you have this queen to h2 check and
that's it king to f1
and now you force a queen trade queen to
h1 check you have to trade queens
queen captures rook captures with check
and now
king to e2 you trade everything off
captures captures and
the resulting end game is completely
winning for
uh for black as uh you wrap two pawns
it's not it's not even close
so instead after this knight captures on
g3
we can't go after the the rook here on
h8 we cannot go after the knight
so what can we play uh well queen to b8
check and this is the only move that uh
allows a white to keep the advantage
but it's very very complicated so the
idea is queen to b8
check and only now after the king moves
now you play
knight captures an h8 but now it's a
little bit different
because now after knights to e2 with
check king to f1 and queen
captures here uh we have this quinta e8
with
check and now we are ready to capture
the knight with the king and also guard
the h5 square
uh from uh being checked by the black
queen so here after king 36 let's say
now we're gonna capture the knight
uh and we would probably see something
like bishop to g7 offering a queen trade
and
this is the position that uh uh would
have occurred uh had uh
both players played uh with the absolute
uh
you know uh accuracy uh the problem is
um even though this position uh okay
white white is the one definitely
playing for a win but uh it's
very hard to say if uh that rasheed
could win this position but that's
besides the point
uh rashid what rasheed meant uh was that
uh
in this position had he found a bishop
to a8 that with both players being low
on time this is move 30 they have to
reach mu 40 to reach time control
uh he would have uh he would have
excellent winning chances and the
position was so complicated that
antoshin who was the lower on time
uh might might have might have succumbed
to
you know all the alt all the intricacies
of the position
uh but getting back to the actual game
rashid played bishop to b7 here
and this is much different because yes
you are threatening checkmate
but uh antoshen played king to c7 and
now there's no point in going queen to
c6
check because the king just goes to b8
and now what do you have here
if you capture the rook there's no
better move queen captures you don't
really have an attack
anymore rook captures on e6 that doesn't
matter just queen to a1 with check
and you will cover the a6 square for
example king g2 queen captures an a2 now
you're
preventing bishop to a6 the threat and
checkmate
and if white goes bishop here to
threaten check made it this way
it's not a problem queen to a6 is in
time to save the day
so this is a problem after the king to
c7 move and uh
here rasheed definitely uh i i mean
probably
realized what he has done so here uh he
captured
the rook right away knight captures an
h8 we have queen captures
and now again uh not going after rook to
rook captures on e6 because rook
captures an e6
again uh you run into this uh ugly
knight captures on g3 move
uh the queen cannot capture because the
bishop is hanging so you'd have to
capture with the pawn
but if you capture with the pawn it is
just very bad you get queen to d4 with
check and then it's just uh incredibly
difficult to play this
king to g2 queen captures on g3 and it's
basically white who's uh
who's fighting for a draw here so what
you would have to do after knight
captures on g3
you'd have to go queen to f7 uh get the
queen into the attack with
check king to b8 and now rook to e8
hoping for for some rook captures here
but it doesn't matter
because black can just trade everything
captures captures and captures
and there's not much uh to be done here
uh uh medina would only have a draw here
queen to d7 check and now you would
be able to continue checking the black
king it doesn't really matter where you
go you you will
always have a check uh not there
obviously uh
king queen to d8 to check and then you
continue checking
uh so that would happen if you go for
something like rook captures on e6 so
bishop to
a8 now but now bishop to a8 is much
different it's not as that bishop to a
uh eight uh two moves ago uh so here we
have rook to d6 this is the only move uh
that uh gives black the advantage and
velocity finds it
so here uh if you continue with queen to
b7 check
king to d8 it's not a problem queen to
b8 with check
again connecting uh with the road the
rook is okay defended by the bishop
came to e7 and now queen captures an a7
check but king of six and the black king
uh you know
uh avoids any any further checks so
instead after look to d6 we have d4
hoping to open up that c file for the
rook but uh
this is simply ignored knight knight
back to f6
uh we have uh queen to b7 with check now
uh but now comes king to d8 uh we have
d5
uh last one last uh you know uh
uh resort before before calling it a day
uh but just knight captures on d5 uh we
have queen to b8 with
check now king to e7 we have bishop
captures on d5
rook captures and queen captures an a7
with check
rook the d7 blocking even though this is
not the best move evolution
uh sorry i'm torsion knows that uh this
is uh this is the way to go
uh we have queen captures on b6 and now
queen to f6
finally mobilizing his pieces uh rashid
even grabs one more pawn with
czech queen captures on c5 king to f7
and now queen to
e3 and even though this is only move 42
and uh rasheed still has a pass pawn
he's down a piece and it was in this
position that
rasheed nish medina resigned to the game
uh as
there really is nothing more to be done
here you could prolong it you could you
know drag it on but
he knows that black is winning here and
that's why he resigned
so a really really intense game and uh
who knows what might have happened but
this is important for you to know this
is the position
that nish medinov was analyzing over and
over i was
after the game was finished for for
years to come and
he analyzed the width with a lot of
other players and uh
this is basically the the the moment
that he thinks that
uh ruined ruined the possibility of him
achieving the grand master title so
bishop to a8
instead of bishop to b7 and okay even
though
the computer with the absolute best
moves uh does not lose the bishop to a8
when you're low on time playing against
ninja medina who's a very tricky player
uh he i believe he would have excellent
chances in
getting his grandmaster title in this
tournament and also as it said
uh in the next game uh he agreed to a
draw in a better position
on move 23 which is something rasheed
would never do
but he was down because he lost this
game and he
drew that one so as he finished the
tournament with eight and a half and he
needed 10 points out of 15
to qualify for a grand master norm uh he
was uh
well i will not say bereft of one but uh
you know
it definitely slipped right through his
hands so now i would just like to
return to this article just uh you know
go through
uh the the final part as it didn't
really make sense for me to show it to
you guys
uh without knowing the game uh but yeah
it says that uh here that he was a very
impulsive man and
losses upset him quite heavily probably
due to that in the next round is medina
agreed to a draw in a better position
after just 23 moves which you already
said
and he couldn't make the grand master
norm by one and a half
point uh so he scored eight and a half
points out of the need at 10.
uh the grand masters norm only proves
that during his most stellar
performances rashid gabatovich was a
grandmaster strength player but simply
never had a chance to achieve that
elusive norm as here
even at the age of 52 he scored uh the
85 percent basically needed of a grand
grandmaster nor
because as he says your memory cannot
register the novelties all that well
your calculation skills get numbed
it's pure physiology and ishmael was
sure that if he won the
game against santoshi in the one that
we've just shown he would have gotten
his norm
uh he would emotionally share his sorrow
with many people managing to convince
most of them
obviously if he won that game uh he
wouldn't have made that quick draw the
next day so rashid
which was pretty sure that a single
chessboard square decided everything for
him so
bishop to a8 instead of bishop to b7 he
was very upset
he thought that if he moved his bishop
just one square further he would have
become a grandmaster
a ridiculous accident though to say the
truth
there is nothing accidental uh in my
humble opinion nez medinav didn't like
uh
bishop to a8 because after that he would
have had to convert his material
advantage in a long and boring endgame
the one that we've shown
but he wanted to checkmate his opponent
his desire to attack
compromise his technique uh why do you
think that i know his chest tastes uh
here's an example
uh he once showed us a beautiful
combination but there was a hole in it
everyone analyzed various moves and
we're glad that they managed to find a
refutation nejmedinov came to us
pushed the pieces off the board and said
you've defiled such a beauty
that's uh the the kind of a guy anez
medina was
and he was so upset that he stopped the
lesson after that and told us to go home
and there's another example he started
uh one of the lessons by saying
i can't understand why they why they're
giving the titles
why aren't they giving titles for
beautiful playing i'm going to show you
a game played by a first category player
i would have awarded him with the
masters title on the spot chess beauty
was more precious to him than chess
truth
uh that's why he remained a grand master
of the beauty and didn't become a grand
master but sport is sport and chess
is a sport uh so that that being said
now you know a little bit more and um
uh what why uh rashid never truly became
a grand master
and uh uh yeah i mean uh he did
get his opportunity to finally win a
norm but it was much too late and he was
already very
very old not very old but not in you
know in his absolute best years where he
uh would probably uh get more than more
than enough points
so if with at the age of 52 he got
eight and a half out of the needed ten
uh you know in his prime years uh
getting the the full ten i don't think
would be much of a problem
uh but here lies the problem for us it
doesn't really matter if we petitioned
for niz medina to be granted the grand
master title it will not be grand master
title it will only be a title of
honorary grand master
and um like i said do do you know any
honorary grand masters chances are you
don't and i think uh
uh granting nesh medina of uh the title
of honorary grand master
would only tarnish the good name of of
rashid medinav
as uh we often said you know there are
there are
many many grand masters who never became
legends but rasheed
may just remain a legend who never
became a grandmaster
so i don't know what's your opinion on
this if you're really up for it i mean
we could we could definitely consider it
because i mean it's not a problem anyone
can make a petition but
uh i i'm i still think i need convincing
because i think
that i i kind of prefer rashid the way
he is
and that way you know he can live on
uh by by us showing it showing his great
games
to our friends in the bar in the library
and um
i don't know i i just i just think it
would spoil a spoil it
and you know everything is done because
without him
receiving the title uh during his
lifetime i i don't know
maybe i'm wrong i don't know i'm very
interested in what you think about this
so do share your uh opinions in the
comment section below as
you know this is quite a long video i
think this is the longest video i've
ever made
so congratulations to everyone who you
know made it all the way
all the way to the end uh so yeah
uh that's the game and the story of the
nish medinov's uh grand master title
hope you guys enjoyed it uh very
looking forward to reading your comments
very much uh i would like to thank uh
alexander klebbering robert leinbach
nikolay akimov mr hoody guy and kevin
lewis for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day